and then the notoriety you said that
even though these were your works you
you know these were your scripts but
your name was either taken out or and
and knowing that that's part of you know
that you're not going to be blasted all
over the trades yeah and being okay with
that
yeah that's that's a part of the life
yeah yes as a working screenwriter this
is this is the thing people who want to
pursue this and I definitely understand
it because it I got the bug early and I
want I mean oh I know I was a writer in
the fourth grade and I say you know it
didn't I didn't choose it it choose it
chose me and okay so that fate question
is decided and we move forward and see
where it takes you but every writer who
does not come from money who does not
come from great resources as most of us
do not there are two tracks to your life
and the woman the first is doing
everything you can with who you are and
your personality toward fulfilling that
the desire the creative need to do these
things and write these scripts and maybe
some of them will get made and that's a
separate discussion
maybe under them but also the second
track being you have to find a way you
have to build for yourself because
nobody else is going to do it for you an
ongoing source of life sustenance
separate from your creative career you
have to build the I think build that
into your plan from the beginning
because even when you do get start
getting hunks of money it comes in hunks
and at times it can be wonderful it can
be very big hunks but when that happens
you have to really know how to how to
turn that money into income in
indefinite income I mean I have so many
friends of course it's so hard and you
struggle and all of a sudden you're
making the big bucks and and your name
is in variety for a few times and all
that and so they run as if you might
work so
hard I really deserve this and they go
up and buy the big house on the hill
which is certainly understandable and
five or six years lady that you know
they're selling it they're desperate and
selling it and they lose it because
every year is not like that it doesn't
always rain gold coins in this business
it's going to be very sporadic take what
you make turn it into income and that's
what I did what we did I advised income
real estate but something so that you
can have a life separate and and assured
mid depends I mean Diana and I we wanted
kids we had I mean when we had kids
pretty pretty soon pretty early on and
the responsibilities mountains and you
got to do both you got to do golf and it
can be done that way
you